- Don't get too close
to your computer screen
or you might get pregnant!
- I know that it's almost no fabric.
- I know that in high
school, and in middle school,
girls wore them above their belt line.
- The thing that comes to mind the most
is that song by Cisco, the Thong Song.
- I think it's gonna feel like my genitals
are getting a hug.
- I don't typically like
things near my butthole region.
- It's like one wrong move, bang, thong,
rips my butthole in half.
- Look at the back!
- I didn't imagine it to be this lacy.
- Where does this strip go?
- Whoa.
- There's no (beep) support there.
- Sliding it up.
- Hee!
- Bending over's so weird.
- It's like a sling that
covers one testicle.
- There is a piece of string
in between my butt cheeks.
And it feels foreign.
- See, I don't know what happened, I was,
when I got back from
putting them on I was okay,
and then I had to adjust
and now I made it worse,
and I don't know what happened, exactly.
I don't know how to make it better.
- I had to use the bathroom one time,
and putting the thong back into position
was a little unusual.
- So I'm peeing, and it's
exceptionally easier to pee
with this thong on, because
there's not much there to it.
- I'm surrounded by women who
are laughing at me right now.
(laughter)
Yeah.
- My butt is uncomfortable.
- I'm like waddling a
little bit as I walk.
- We're walking to Chipotle.
God, it's like riding up my (beep) crack.
And it's hot as (beep) out here.
- I'm not used to the way this feels yet.
But I have noticed that it's
kind of an interesting feeling,
knowing I've got a secret.
- The amazing thing about the thong is,
I feel remarkably fast in it.
- Ya'll, it's really
riding up my (beep) hole.
- Well, now you know how it feels.
- But it doesn't feel that bad.
- Okay, well.
- I kinda like it.
- [Voiceover] Settle down, settle down.
- My, my business flops
around a little bit,
but other than that, I feel aerodynamic.
- It's not as comfortable
as I was expecting it to be,
to be honest.
- I feel like I could
wear this to the gym.
- Every time I go down to do a dead lift,
it rides up my butt crack,
which is a little unpleasant.
- There were roses and
there were thorns to it.
There were highs and there were lows.
- I never quite got used
to the feeling of fabric
running up and down my buttcrack.
- Did I feel sexy? Of course I did.
Did I feel ridiculous? Of course I did.
But it's because I have a penis.
- I give ya'll mad props.
Like, ya'll always have
strings stuck up your (beep).
Like, that's not something
I really wanna do every day.
But it wasn't as uncomfortable
as I thought it would be.